[Music]
in cured news submitted by g-code the
Danks the co yeah this is a good one a
man with a stutter has found his new
voice by speaking in an accent
Wow Wow that's cool so you didn't
stutter anymore oh my god what accent
please tell me it's a soda smooth and
it's like a British lady or something
Nick he's 28 years old and I'm gonna
show you a video a word he's trying to
explain this whole situation oh my
wording please let it be video that you
guys are still doing it like this but
you don't have like a TV up already
we're low budget alright there's a TV
back there we keep it ghetto yeah don't
get mad like guys sellouts got a TV now
people work show sending me links to you
know the lazy susans oh cool I like
that's a good idea but it's okay I'll
just be more work till I set it and then
fix it it just makes it look more ghetto
though yeah yeah they want they like the
ghetto here we go struggle with some
conversation of wisdom just a WoW yes a
pretty bad treat you differently yeah
some people some people try say the word
for you are there now speaking more
could be a beatboxer yeah confident good
morning hi my name's Nick and and when
you have a spotter and it's the hardest
hardest name to say to someone when
you've ever started the hardest hardest
hardest word is to say your name right
when I meet out people in public and I
try say my name is
but now with the Irish nickk nickk nickk
nickk heartwarming story wait was he
still in his accent yeah wasn't sure
going in and out oh I can't even tell so
what a suppose you do he says it's Irish
I know what is this normal yeah English
ladies British news you know you know
what I always wonder you know when
people are deaf and then they talk what
accent is that like say you're Irish
yeah you've never heard what an Irish
accent sounds like and then you're deaf
and then they you learn how to talk like
you're a born deaf or yeah you're born
deaf speaking in whatever you were
taught so whoever however you got it
right hoping you but I know because I'm
saying is if you're deaf why would you
be speaking in a British accent you know
what I mean wait but then how do you
learn how to talk some deaf people can
talk like it's like you know they they
don't know that this sound is coming out
of their mouth they're just making this
sound based off what they see out of it
because your your mouth moves
differently depending on what like even
the shape of your mouth depending on
what country you grow up in is
completely different so maybe they're
reading the mouth and then that's how it
sounds like Helen Keller
she's Vienna yeah but the way she speaks
like a lot of deaf people speak like
that they're speaking English what is
the story behind Helen Keller who's born
deaf blind and what mute yeah yeah
imagine having to learn how to read and
write so he just came out oh man I don't
even know how they did it visually
feeling things you know yeah this
teacher helped her yeah you try to
explain they imagine if you don't you
can't see in here and I have to explain
it this is the bottle how would you
explain it to somebody's a genius yeah
each other's love anyway yeah so Nick
here are you saying that he had his
stutter his entire life not until one of
his colleagues suggested for him to try
out different accents and then when he
landed on the Irish accent that's when
he was like oh my gosh it just
completely went away that's such a
random suggestion though how did he even
come up with that I know
that maybe Bart and Joe were like his
friends or something maybe relaxes your
mind its stuttering a mental thing I
don't know my uncle stutter is like a
[ __ ] and so does my cousin that
your your mouth can't move as fast as
what your brain is thinking that's
everybody though I'm just saying that
physical is it mental Camille can we
Google with well he's saying that he'd
been to a ton of speech therapists and
doctors and they had never suggested the
accent technique yes if that's the case
then it kind of makes sense because
before you speak these accent you have
to think about how you're going to say
it so it'll slow it down a little bit
maybe that so I might come back if he
masters it yeah so he has to go to a
different action in a different accent
so they even reported in this article
here that Emily Blunt we was previously
revealed in interviews that she also had
a stutter that she had the speech
impediment when she was ten she
developed it and then her teacher made
her play the lead in a play and she
suggested an accent and that helped her
with her speech oh they're saying they
each therapist they're like yeah there's
not a common technique that we suggest
no really yeah because it's kind of
still it also is it a little bit weird I
mean feel like British and your
everybody around you is British and all
of a sudden you're speaking in a
different accent they teasing you for
something else totally kept it perfect
yeah got the flannel and everything by
your over here little spider get a real
teardrop that's all I'm missing in the
three dots Oh eyeliner oh yeah if it
doesn't even have to be like a like a
language accent it's like an East LA
type of [ __ ] that'd be [ __ ] tight
dude like some subculture well there's a
lot of accents here in the United States
more than we realize
yeah ton there's differently yes but
especially the East Coast yeah no Boston
nude you know New York often I always
know about how people say my name where
I can figure out where they're from Eric
you feel like Eric you know Texas is
like Eric you know it's like yeah it's
all different types of names it's just
pure lazy oh say my full name you get
four letters on my [ __ ] how many US
states have you traveled to do oh man
I'm almost all of them Jesus dude
is there a one that you haven't been to
you and you're like it's not worth going
there I think I think one of the Dakotas
I haven't been to forget those two
Dakotas useless amount of Dakotas like
Buffalo New York is a place that nobody
really needs to visit they got buffalo
wings we've been there we did a show
there yeah but niagra's Niagara Falls is
right there they get that nice casino
right Canada sites the better yeah you
can go on that sign are you guys travel
a lot you guys I used to because we
should do a lot of like stand-up shows
like we should do a lot of college shows
oh we kind of chilled out a little bit
would you guys do it again I miss it I
miss my performance but it's just the
time and the traveling like it I have
chokes do an accent alright for one show
okay choking the Chinese accent for once
no like if we have a show on Saturday we
have to be there like by Friday or like
I don't know it just gets hectic if the
shows on Saturday and you gotta go all
the to the East Coast and enjoy and you
just gotta leave the writing yeah you
know I always feel like when you do
those kind of shows you're just gonna
you're just basically traveling to pick
up your check yeah yeah yeah yeah you
don't get to see the city you don't get
to know you been to like 30 States
how was it I don't [ __ ] know I know
what the airport was like yeah I know
what the show was like I know what my
hotel was like yeah it's part of travel
is like you know it's the travel the
actual travels its lucky parts you know
no place those st. Louis was dope st.
Louis during springtime [ __ ] I don't
know if I've ever been there
I love st. Louis happy the st. Louis was
alright or Kansas that's just the states
I mean there's so many city she can go
to oh yeah I always tell people the
United States is actually a very
beautiful country
she gave it
chance when people think like oh when
you go on vacation what you go to go to
France oh you got to go to like it's
actually some really really nice place
there's the terrain and just a climate
it all changes in Montana Montana's got
some beautiful play the Kalispel and you
know there's a lot of great stuff around
ya United States so give it a chance
everybody the thing I like about
traveling though it's I want to go to a
country that I can't speak the language
yeah me too I like that I don't know if
it's the challenge per se but I feel
like it's just more eye-opening so
that's that's what I like it's like a
different world i phone you just plant
your phone you go to google translate
but it doesn't work though it does work
I was just I did it in Spain I was in
Spain I just be like I understand I
would just be like blah blah blah
and they would say it and they would get
today we get to juice that's a little
different you know me like specifically
like for example like when I went to
like Taiwan like we're not we're not
going there just to go see like tours
that we want to explore the country you
know what I mean so it's like a
completely different feel and a vibe to
it versus if I wanted a that's why I
like my girlfriend understand why I
don't really want to go to like I would
like to but I'm not interested in going
to like I don't know like Britain or
something yeah it's like the culture is
not different enough yeah so you want to
be like an alien planet like that
different [ __ ] right there if you could
that would be crazy how close I mean
space SpaceX they're working on right I
mean who knows what that company will be
like in 10 years but then just enough to
where you're not in a place where it's
so far and where you feel like you're
gonna be harvest yet for body parts
exactly that's Korean I [ __ ] like
shake the hand of a five-year-old that
he takes my organs yeah I mean like ha
ha ha ha what that [ __ ] dude yeah you
shake your panties as a syringe a big
fat boy
what do you ever want to be like
blindfolded and not know which I never
want to be blackballed in ever in my I
don't want to do that I wanna know but
you know you go like like let's say I
blindfolded Yoona and I took you to a
mall you know just a mall like be
surprised
I am surprised how metropolitan cities
are all the same yes yes you know like I
was saying I went to New Zealand yeah I
was in
Oakland and I was like this us exactly
it's like there's a mobile station
there's a movie poster same hotels me
personally I'm a beach guy I like beach
vacations I like tropical I want like my
I want to open the door to my room and
then like I could see the water oh oh
yeah one thing that's nice about Europe
like you fish is like Germany for
instance they have such a mix of like
you know here's a twelve hundred year
old you know whatever and then it's this
really modern that's true I want to see
a Filipino man walking up the [ __ ]
tree
I mean timing up and getting a coconut
and then like cracking in and we're like
drinking it together watching the ocean
you and the Philippine I mean that's not
even their old girlfriend she's not
invited just go back to your [ __ ]
room me and AJ beat me in the Filipino
guy me and mr. agro so you can think of
[Music]